in light of the events of the last 12
months
perhaps I have more to reflect on than
most
[Music]
the royal family is in genuine crisis
[Music]
have Royal scandals damaged the
country's reputation the house of
Windsor should be binding the nation
together setting an example of idealized
family life it's a situation that can't
help but affect the stability of the
country
for years I've called for a more modern
monarchy that reflects the world outside
I don't think it's my behavior that's
threatening its survival you as Future
King have a duty
people won't never understand how it's
really been for me
I never stood a chance
she's a breaking point because of the
way she feels she's been treated they
see her as a threat
remember the one condition the one rule
you remain loyal to this family
you're inside it
yes it's a system The Better or For
Worse we're all stuck in it
it feels it's all about to erupt
she opens her mouth and hand grenades
come out she wants to tear down the
temple let's go for it what the hell is
she doing
it won't go quietly I'll battle till the
end
belong to the Past
and the world will move on
and we'll be left with nothing
[Music]
how did it come to this
[Music]